bathing whether to berserk let's bezerk
we'll play a different variation of
Sicilian that variation was fun but I
want to play dragon
he plays open Sicilian
if you place closed Sicilian play a six
cool guy everyone is great
that's just me answering on behalf of
everyone
how are you cool guy
things very well
by playing the whole nine hours
I've already played 50 minutes so we'll
see
I do have to be a bit careful this game
because I'm giving him time odds now I
don't have increments let me play d5
here
oh this is actually an interesting line
here I like can play
I play this from we play this line from
whites perspective
fact that he's thinking makes me a bit
more comfortable the flight is very well
prepared in this position it's scary for
black
was taken is asking if I can play a Slav
okay if my opponent plays d4 I will
consider playing Slav what about semi
Slav because I play Queens gambit
declined and semi Slav would be a nice
compromise
on a truce off
we possibly do that
a passed pawn 99 this is not a French
but it highly resembles a French if
these are all very typical French type
things in the position
and
I would say that this is a French
players dream is a position like this
where White has essentially no active
play
if you try and search for a plan here
from light it's so difficult to find
anything
and meanwhile black will keep developing
[Music]
improving the long-term plan is just a
push on the queenside
what is white doing this black is
controlling all areas of the board
I've ran into people who play Bishop II
one and under 93
so this could be a long game because
he's gonna take some time to think
which I can't blame him for
I would think to in this position if I
were whites
I am Creedy
the new name
okay semi Slav I used to play this I'm
you Slav internments Percy Hepworth
thank you for the follow
lady choose a decent move
I want to consider things Queen b6 is
natural let's play Queen b6 sometimes
white wants to play c4
preventing me from playing c4
he plays c3 so he really wants to play
d4 but he can't play d4 cuz I have way
too many attackers on d4 I'm just gonna
play an improving move
there's a b7
someday maybe in the future I'll have a
CH for ideas probably not anytime soon
I mean I just want to stop him from
playing g4
I do understand why he played this move
c3 was to prevent me from playing c4 or
basically discourage me from playing c4
but he could respond with t4
so
but we won't go into that
lesbo shipped each 300kg six
I've had this exact structure so many
times before he wastes no time and takes
the night um and then plays d4
interesting
this is slightly new
play Bishop III next
now each war is a real possibility
before it's a possibility fives a
possibility just what to do first
think of if I play h4 I don't know if I
have a threat you just ignore it
you
I'm gonna start with a 5 he wants to
draw I'm not accepting a draw
my bishop bishop happier
it take
the tension
wanna play b4
in case you didn't know this when will
help will help quite a bit
I am Rosen smash
the yeah so the the prefix for my emotes
is I am rose and not I am Rosen I have
to get that fixed it's gonna require
like a contacting which support or
something
the capability of changing my emote
prefix now that I'm a partner okay so
let's think here B for some point he
probably wants to take and then play 94
I have to act somewhat quickly
we're considering just playing c4 and
then b4
that looks so simple I'm just gonna do
it it's just one of these about instinct
type things where if he were if he did
have the chance to take and play 94 I
think it would have made life difficult
but now like his piece is just there on
squares but they're doing nothing and
now he's begging me not to play before
we won't play before right away
I'm going to start with King d7 my king
is super safe in the center
and the strategy in this position is
pretty interesting for black because I
have potential now I have less potential
on the kingside itch whereas a good move
I should probably should have play h4
myself that was a missed opportunity
my g5 is coming
that's too bad
well time for b4
to think
let's tick
mine's
my Chi 5
[Music]
after I don't want to take
option
yeah I should not have allowed h4
the careless on my parts
okay take on g5f seven would have been
really annoying to defend I'll play
Bishop e5
and
was supposed to be a classical game is
now turning into a very
annoying
somewhat rapid situation where he has
increments he's up a lot of time on the
clock
Lexia hello Wow
all guys for auto mod thank you so much
2x villager and
[Music]
Nathan for just making so many commands
this is so useful thank you for
introducing me tonight bot Bishop d2
what does this move
playable
okay I'm going to bring I'm gonna
treyton and then bring the night to be
three
you
you
as really just the first plant that came
to mind but it looks powerful if I got a
night to be three and get my rook to the
a file
penetrate via a1
only problem is as night is going to be
attacking this pawn
that could be a big problem
you
yeah
you
you
be very big problems
this could turn bad
you
you
you
okay I don't see what else to do my
position is definitely much worse and I
have to play four tricks which is not a
pleasant situation to be in
me too I can't defend h5
he's going to take the pawn
the good news is that b2 is not defended
currently I can have one move with
initiative Queen a to probably doesn't
do much
wait a minute client take on h5 probably
not yet
let's click we need to first
we also have night take T to Brooke take
T to
he's not a sex always
okay Queenie - it is
and so much regrets
not playing this each [ __ ] move
it's going to take some sort of miracle
to win this
II won so he's being extra careful
nc6 probably
just so he doesn't have night at 6:00
with tempo
my king is like a safe around c6
and it's still going to take time for
him to make
progress on the kingside
just a question can they make progress
on the queenside moves the night back to
f4
let's play queen bee one
I might just pop into e4 see what
happened but wait what why did I play
Queen b1
happen
I
I was so excited about this e4 square
I'm not gonna resign cuz I broke a one
ideas but that was really bad how does
that even happen
lack of focus
Rosen's fail
in Finland emotes he's going to Queen
we hope to save
you
mmm okay hi resign that was really bad
oh I need to take a break or do i I mean
okay the position was looking pretty bad
for me but why would I play queen bee
one
I guess I was losing
makes sense like ice like for some
reason thought the fish was on c1
that doesn't make any sense is trying to
find some explanation for this
okay let's try and suppress that memory
and go back I think this is a very key
moments like the position would have
been very comfortable if I play h4 here
you
then I basically dictate the tension in
the position
I allow file or I allow at least one
file to open up on the kingside problem
is h4 and IG v is just so strong
you
it was I was a short position h5s a
long-term weakness not sevens or targets
okay
I'm sorry to let everyone down
uh yeah there was some very bad been
flying gold at least like we never
played queen bee one lesson learned